Your weapons look fantastic.
It's time to see how they
hold up in our weapons test.
We're gonna lead it all
off with a kill test.
Doug?
Bladesmiths, to see
what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do,
we'll take your bagh nakh
and deliver multiple
slashes, and thrusts,
and claw at this big carcass.
Josh, you're up first.
You ready for this?
- So ready.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[INAUDIBLE] I
want to thank you.
All right, Josh, first
up, it's comfortable.
My three fingers
in the middle allow
me to grasp on to
the claws easily,
and not feel that
it's gonna impede
my movement with the hand.
The clawing is very deep.
Your slashes cut deep
into this pig carcass.
Overall, your bagh
nakh will kill.
Good job.
Thank you.
HOST: All right,
Chad, your turn.
You ready?
- Yes, sir.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, Chad,
first off, the handle--
it's on the thinner side.
There's a little bit
of movement there.
But the positions where you
have the claw is secure.
It's safe.
They're razor sharp.
On the lacerations
there, the slicing--
it cuts deeply.
Overall, your weapon will kill.
Thank you.
Ben?
Bladesmiths, to test the
strength and durability
of your bagh nakh, I'm gonna
be clawing and stabbing
away at these logs.
Remember, this test is all about
what happens to your blades,
not what happens to the log.
Josh, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm ready.
I'm nervous about
the strength test.
I'm worried about the
tip, because the tip is
the thinnest part of the blade.
There's a chance of a fracture.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, Josh, the claws
held up very well.
There's no mark on them that
they've ever even seen a tree,
but you lost your tips.
Yeah.
BEN: The first one
went as I started
to pry, but the second tip--
it cracked as soon
as I stabbed in.
I liked the feeling
of these in my hands.
They were comfortable to wield.
But you know, you can't deny
that they're not there anymore.
Chad, you're up next.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
After seeing Josh's
tips break, I'm nervous.
It might happen to mine.
If you didn't get your
heat treat just right,
they're gonna break.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, Chad, you
lost one of your tips.
The other one was scaring me.
But it's in one piece.
It held up well.
I like that you did Damascus.
I like the pattern of it.
It's really pretty.
Overall, well done.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, what
started as a round
one nuts and bolts challenge
came down to these bagh nakh.
Both of you put in an
incredible amount of work.
Unfortunately, in this
arena of competition,
there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Chad, congratulations.
You are a new "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Good job.
Josh, unfortunately, your bagh
nakh did not make the cut.
Josh, you brought us a matched
pair of beautiful knives--
very sharp and
comfortable in the hand.
But unfortunately,
in the strength test,
yours took more damage.
And that's why I
had to let you go.
I understand.
Josh, please
surrender your weapons.
JOSH: I'm a little discouraged,
a little disappointed,
but I'll bounce back.
I'm really proud to
make it this far.
To me, it's real
acknowledgment that I
have a skill set for this.
And I'm gonna keep pursuing
it, keep getting better,
learn from my mistakes.